[Music]
yeah cool well thanks for doing this
yeah I appreciate it it's great to be in
your studio and you're definitely
somebody who I've wanted to talk to you
for a long time and like I said earlier
you know our social circles overlap we
got lots of mutual friends and and it's
just it's exciting for me to meet you
and to talk to you man
I think the first thing I'm interested
in in in hearing a little bit about it's
just this podcast journey that you've
been on you know I started mine five
years ago it's been transformational in
my life it's just it's enriched me in so
many ways an incredible thing and so I'm
interested in you know what what
motivated you to decide to get into this
and and what the experience has been
like yeah I mean five years Wow I've
been at it a year so just over a year
and it really was almost on a whim like
mine yep I think most people know the
story of the Ark of the Silurian we were
we being me and my manager who had been
with for a long time who stuck with me
he you know he was trying to figure out
a way for me to just do something and
sort of as the cycling platform and
sports platform in a way the cancer
platform went away you know what is a
platform that we could we could find or
our going get and so he was on me for
well over a year do just just start a
podcast and you know everybody you know
everybody's still you know who you're
you know your true friends want to sit
down and rap and just just go do it and
it's like yeah I wanted I didn't want to
start it actually because I was afraid
I'd just kind of get sick of it and
mm-hmm
a weekly show as you know is kind of a
pain that's a lot of us a lot of month
yeah and so I just started it on the web
and and it's been it's been great it's
been great to talk to people it's been
great to quote-unquote work uh-huh no
because I try to not I don't just have
somebody on and sit down and go okay
what am what do you wanna talk about
yeah like I dig into their lives I spend
days thinking about their lives reading
about their lives so that reading about
somebody else's life has been you know
I've been done homework in a long long
time yeah it is homework I mean if you
want to
right and you really want to deliver you
know something solid you got it you got
to put the time and and I think people
don't really appreciate how much time it
takes to do it well so and you've been
doing it well and I feel like you really
found your groove with stages like
that's just that's compelling you know
right behind the knots right yeah the
spin-off of the foreword which again was
was totally random last minute started
as one idea that didn't materialize and
then morphed into another idea which I
didn't think would work and then it I
just you know recruited an old friend
who was a who you just met it yeah I was
I mean I'm at this event I'm Sinkin and
he's the dude who's like filming the
whole thing and he comes up to me after
I talked is like I love your talk gives
me a we do hat he's like you know we
should connect I was like wait I know
this guy right just I've been trying to
connect with light because like you know
I'd connect I email you and then a
couple days would go by and I'm like I
don't know if this is happening or not
he's like I'll ping them and then just
email back so here we are no that's cool
man I mean are there you know who are
your who your dream guests that you're
trying to track down like who would you
really like to sit down and talk to on
the weekly show maybe somebody asked you
the other day about it all right buddy
Oprah oh yeah I'll talk to she'll be
yeah she owes me she'll come on the show
who was it and somebody asked me the
data I didn't have a great answer
like I don't did you reach on Ronson's
book and so uh he wrote this amazing
book called so you've been publicly
shamed I think that's the title of it
and it's kind of about me you know what
happens when somebody missed steps and
then the internet piles on and the lives
get wrecked in the wake of that and
people just kind of move on it's a it's
a it's a cultural phenomenon that I
think we're seeing more and more of it
it's you know something that you lived
through and and you know have a unique
perspective on but I think in the
context of you know of that and and you
know what I said in my email to you like
I'm interested in in how you move
forward from anything like that and as
somebody who's you know faced adversity
in my own life and
of whether you know certain storms not
on the level that you you've had to of
course but you know how do you pick up
the pieces and move forward right and
and you know obviously name your podcast
that's kind of the theme of you know how
you're trying to live your life and
rebuild this and I think in the context
of the conversation that surrounds you
what gets eclipsed are all these other
qualities that made you successful
because the doping thing l'm so large
that we don't get to talk about these
other aspects of our career and you know
you're a kid who had 15 you're out there
mixing it up with Mark Allen and and
Mike pig-like you know just basically
this raw talent who you know took his
talent and fuelled it with mindset and
extreme preparation and focus that no
one had ever seen you know in your sport
that took you to a certain height and so
I'm interested in the mindset he's that
you know that that focus and yeah I
think it is about you that that allowed
you to kind of you know achieve that
height that all got lost rich you know
the reality is here's the truth right
and and we and the problem and with the
whole story is that we still have we
still don't have the truth right
which isn't sort of a [ __ ] up thing to
think about so for all these years we
pedaled for lack of a better word a
narrative a story so that the training
was harder and and more cutting-edge
than anybody else the the technology
piece the testing the reconnaissance the
composition of thing all these things we
said were the reason that we were the
best mm-hmm there was one part of it we
said we didn't talk about right hmm
doesn't take away the fact that all
those things happened and they all made
the difference the last part
unfortunately the generation that we
were in everybody had to have that part
they but they didn't have the first ten
parts so literally overnight it shifted
to and again this what you just talked
about when the internet piles on and the
media piles on and people pile on and
commenters pile on it shifted - ah it
was all about that one thing and all
these ten of the things the training the
reconnaissance the composition of team
the tactics that was a bunch of [ __ ]
he just gave us a bunch of [ __ ] for
15 years so while this rise wasn't
totally true the fall isn't totally true
either because what happened in the
middle is you had an agency in you sada
who came and said some very intense
damaging and untrue things they said
that this athlete at the athlete at the
center of it all is the biggest fraud in
history of sport think about that they
said that this athlete and his team ran
the most sophisticated doping program in
the history of the world think about
that
but there's truth in that isn't there no
no no there's not true that so when you
violate but the work and the worst is
this athlete forced young impressionable
men to put deadly substances into their
body think about that so I get it I get
that they said that that was part of as
as the report came out and as the
takedown took place they needed an it
they needed PR points bullet points
talking points and those were their
points and so I understand I'm not I
know why Travis Tygart says those things
cuz he was about reinforcing his report
there's a lot of truth to the report but
those things those bullets with those
talking points are not true
so when you when you measure run and not
that it matters right but I understood
recover from those things yeah well when
that that's the primary narrative and
you're somebody who's always you very
savvy with the media and you've you've
always done a very good job of trying to
control the narrative in the story and
that was a situation that you couldn't
control and and and I know for the rest
of time I won't be able to control right
but it's the beauty of having your own
podcast do you think that other teams
had had had protocols that were as
sophisticated as postal look I'm gonna
I'm gonna boil this down to very very
very simply and and and straight out of
the truth here in the postal case and
this is not this year this is and this
is not off the record these are public
transcripts the the world will and
should know in the postal case we have
to depose everybody mm-hmm one of the
depositions that we've taken is Tyler
Hamilton the line of questioning to
Tyler Hamilton was because Tyler to back
up a little bit Tyler goes from postal
to CSC to Phonak you probably know
enough to be one like Rock racing at the
right that's another so the line of
question goes like this was there more
doping at postal or CSC and the answer
was CSC was there more dope doping at
CSC or Phonak the answer was Phonak so
our system look it doesn't matter I mean
they were all we were all dirty the
teams were all dirty the team they were
all that at the game they were all
playing the game but and again I feel
silly talking about this because it
really doesn't matter what I think or
what I say but we I'm just telling you
we were not the most sophisticated
system and that year the bullseye yeah
and again that goes back to me
understanding why they why they did what
they did and why they said what they
said I'm not I'm not by the way I
wouldn't change a thing
that's something that I'm interested in
here your life I think I've heard you
say like you know you you're you like
your life better now yeah
so all things being equal if you could
go back if you didn't make a comeback
and all that kind of stuff and you could
have ended live with this yeah none of
this that I would have and and would you
would you trade what's going on now for
for that life no I wouldn't I wouldn't
change a thing because why because and
by the way to there's a lot of stops
along this train you know that could
have been none of this could have
happened some of this could have
happened or what happened happened could
have happened right and so the option of
nobody ever finding out it never been
exposed me continuing to just you know
live the life I was living I wouldn't I
don't want that when you were in that
position though did you like feel the
weight of trying to no carry that law or
did you just compartmentalize it yeah
that was that was completely
compartmentalized I mean that was the
way the game was played at the time and
you know some people don't like to hear
that for a variety of reasons but that
that's that's the way me and my peers
played the game mm-hmm and so and then
the next option is is some sort of a
hybrid option where you sada wants to
work together and you know that my deal
is the same deal as everybody else my
deal is the same as George and the same
as Levi and the same as ty they're in
the same same as everybody which is you
know this six-month offseason suspension
and come help us and but that wasn't the
deal
and so I didn't I didn't you know the
message to me was loud and clear hey
come out with your hands up we have you
surrounded
which that that never works well with me
mm-hmm so I said [ __ ] you right but it
but but it wasn't it wasn't the same
message but it did smoother hearing are
there so I say [ __ ] you and it's World
War 3 total meltdown everything goes
away all the platforms all the sponsors
the lawsuits pile up everything and so
that's it's been five years and I think
not back up I don't think I know the way
I operate as a man as a husband as a
father as a friend as a host of a
podcast as a teammate as a businessman
as a anything is far better than it ever
would have been and that's important
let's sorry to interrupt yeah but the
most important thing is I know and I say
this all the time I know who my friends
are
whereas go back six or seven years when
the [ __ ] hits the fan and ever
you know fleas or whatever that's that's
and and and I have great memories but
when I look back on the people that sort
of populated that scene you know those
weren't friends and not that they were
bad friends or they were mean or they
were vindictive date but they but they
just weren't there for the ride and the
better and they're gone
which is a bummer but the better thing
are the real highlight isn't is they're
people that while there are people that
surprise you because it turns out they
weren't friends the [ __ ] it's a fan and
you're public enemy number one and all
of a sudden they're people calling going
hey let's go get a beer let's go play
golf
mmm let's go for a bike ride I'm like
where'd you come from mm-hmm so they
they weren't interested in kissing ass
toast in the champagne you know riding
around in the team car they were they
didn't care about that but they were a
friend and so the journey from from that
place to where you are now requires like
you know grappling with anger and
resentment you know it's like as
somebody who's like a long time sober
they kind of say in recovery like uh you
know justifiable anger is like your your
death now like to hold on to that even
when you're right like you want to be
happy or do you want to be right yeah
and you know you're somebody who's
fueled by you know in many ways in the
past like you know there is an anger
component horse has fueled you and and
that's I've noticed you know from the
sidelines that slowly dissipated I mean
because there was still a lot of that
you know in the Oprah interview era
right and so how have you traversed that
to kind of come to terms with that and
begin to let go of it I mean look I mean
I've done a few major interviews since
it went down obviously there's everybody
points to the Oprah one which they
should and Oprah had its reasons for
happening Oprah wasn't while it
certainly appears that the timing wasn't
right it had to happen then and it
didn't go well
and then you're right I was I was I was
a a certain guy at the time so if you
compare
Oprah to Joe Rogan to ish years ago to
Howard Stern six months ago those are
different I mean I got somebody going
after Rogan and staring people were like
dude why didn't you just say that on
Oprah mm-hmm I think we'd have been fine
yeah you weren't you weren't that ready
no I mean and and again
Oprah felt rushed and in maybe in some
senses it was but that's a different
person and that's nothing mattered if
she wasn't rushed I don't think right
like you were just you were holding on
to a certain perspective on the whole
situation at that time that was gonna
come out and matter who was interviewing
and that's a whole process of of me just
living my life and living with this
story and living with people's reaction
and living with therapy living with
what's the therapy all about I was just
me just you know no kind of special
magic there I mean just standard therapy
that I do solo I do with Anna and it
does solo we do with the kids just more
just conversation on on our lives and
you know obviously with the children we
tried to to help them navigate this as
teenagers as best they could but to be
honest I mean that the the more
important element is just has just come
through and it's it is therapy in a
sense that just in conversations with
people whether they're in an airport
over a cup of coffee or even over email
I mean just understanding where people
were when all this went down and how it
affected them so that that to me has
been the most important part and so I
just let go of like I mean you saw
deferred okay I get it
mm-hm I get it I don't know I don't I
don't think they're necessarily
honorable or or or honest but hey I
don't care I mean I'm not that hit that
did that is I cannot change that right
and so you know almost almost all of its
gone away not all of it but almost all
of it well you got one big thing looming
over you right now you got the one big
lawsuit is
is that is May the trial date that's
sometime in May I mean what's that like
to wake up every day with that I never
hundred milli you don't think about it
we're gonna win the case yeah that's the
Lance Armstrong mindset back to the
mindset we're gonna win the case and the
government cannot prove damages well is
it it's a nation yes so look the case
the case is about one thing it's not
about who's a good guy bad guy and
ending any blue boot none of that
it's about damages and they freely admit
that they cannot prove that they were
damaged yeah there's liability and then
there's damages I mean liabilities you
know it looks like it's pretty clear but
how do you establish I mean is there
anybody walking around who says you know
I love going to the post office and
waiting in a long line but now I'm not
now I'm gonna use UPS because of what
happened like that's that's a tough I'm
not gonna say my Christmas right now in
use the post office no I use them all
the time you do and I said a monster
like I loved I love representing the
Postal Service riding around in Europe
with United States anything on your
chest and and on the the top step on the
champs-elysees with the national anthem
with the United States both I love that
mm-hmm like I wasn't ashamed of that I
wasn't I didn't think that was a goofy
sponsor like some people thought I was
proud of that and so but look I mean in
judge Cooper's courtroom we had a
summary judgment hearing and and and he
pushed them he said you got to give me a
number he said your honor we don't have
a number
mm-hmm and this is a public proceeding
so I'm not saying anything out of class
here and he pressed him three or four
times he said we don't have a number and
judge Cooper said okay well I'll make it
real easy name one client that you lost
because of all this was that in summary
judgment proceedings right yeah in
November any and they said we can your
honor we can't we don't have one right
that still got five summary judgment
though yeah but it's hard it's it's
almost impossible and went on summary
judgment want to be appealed they don't
wanna get appeal they don't want to get
overturned it just it's easy for them to
say I'm just call it that you're
decide right which is fine I mean it
let's get let's get back to the mindset
piece you know I'm interested in kind of
exploring that you know as an athlete
myself and a lot of athletes that listen
to this show you know what is it that
you think back to the original question
really like what is it that you think
set you apart and allowed you to you
know sort of succeed on the level that
you did everything else aside I mean you
know one of the things you did is you
kind of came into cycling and you you
reimagine the schedule first of all
because everyone was doing all these
races and you're like the only one that
matters is Tour de France I'm just gonna
focus on that I'm gonna sidestep all
this other stuff that was new and
different at the time and the ability to
just kind of hone in you know with that
singular you know ability to just lock
in on one thing and and you know really
set up your entire life yet around that
one goal I think it's interesting and
just you know what is it you know what
is it you think when you look around at
other athletes triathletes cyclists
whatever that you think that you have
that other people didn't have I mean
what can be learned from that the
scheduling part wasn't I mean Andorian
did that too although some of those
years he did the Tour of Italy but he
you know he figured out then his home
country of Spain the biggest bike race
in the world and the only bike race was
really the Tour but that's the same in
every country so especially as Americans
we certainly don't know what the Vuelta
is or the Giro or the classic they don't
know any of that [ __ ] in the end we know
the tour because of Greg LeMond and so
it was easy for me to just say okay I'm
coming back from from cancer nobody
thinks that I'm gonna amount to anything
anyways I mean I could barely get at
them and I begged to be on the Postal
Service team and you know this all meets
the comeback meets the team firing
Johnny well it's hiring Johan Bruyneel
and and really I mean a lot of this had
to do with his vision
his genius that he was and still is but
that was a you know for he and I we
formed a perfect partnership where I was
willing to do the work he was motivated
to lay out the agenda and the plan of
course you know I'm not going to
discount or ignore the fact that Micheli
Ferrari was an amazing trainer the best
in the business and probably still is to
this day so the way that all came
together the athlete my willingness to
work hard the training and then johan's
vision of how we were gonna how we were
gonna do this and he truly believed it
like he and all that mixed in with this
sort of [ __ ] you attitude because you
know certainly at that time the fact
that we called 20 teams and 19 of them
just literally hung up within five
seconds I mean the chip on my shoulder
back in 98 99 was tremendous and so that
worked and and I think a lot of athletes
use that as I know a lot of athletes use
that as motivation and even if there's
not a real reason to have a chip they'll
go make one up I'd make them up right
yeah I remember you said on Rogen that
you used to concoct stories oh yeah that
out of the race into the real world and
get yourself yeah a bunch of trouble
yeah it turns out they're great guys
it's not a ultimately it's not a
sustainable fuel source though right is
it and like now you have to find a new
you know a new motivation to get out on
the bike do what you do and and you know
a different you know a different set of
ground rules from that and so you know
what does that look like I mean I don't
compete mm-hmm I mean I could you would
though I can't but I can I can do so you
can compete but cycling oh you can oh so
that's been listed right on well the
you know the the fine print says that
after four years an athlete given a
lifetime ban that after four years they
can compete it's a little bit limited I
couldn't go do Kona couldn't do anyways
there's a bunch of certain races you
kind of yeah right right right but I got
like last spring I started riding a lot
and I got back into riding for a couple
of reasons but I started riding a lot
and I started feeling fit I was like
I'll go do some of these gravel races
they're all in sanctioned
a bunch of cool people do them they're
hard and I get in these races with these
young kids forty had before tea I was 45
at the time I'd get in a race of the 25
year old pro and you know next thing I
know there's two guys left it's me and
him mm-hmm and I'm like well yeah of
course I'm here because I'm me I'm
supposed to be here but the 25 year old
pro lives and breathes and his obsessed
with cycling and he eats perfectly any
trains perfectly and he arrests a lot at
that and me being me who just kind of
rides for fun gets in that situation so
my head says of course I'm here but then
all of a sudden the body the warning
lights start coming on right but you
still have the you still have some
semblance of the win at all costs
mentality I don't wait up but for me
it's either just ride for a fun ride to
stay fit ride to be with your friends
and not compete or you're all-in you
live like a monk
q right you completely dedicate all of
you know every aspect of your life for a
goal and I don't want to do that anymore
mm-hmm I don't and that's so you have to
make peace with the fact that you're
gonna get your ass kicked here and there
by these young kids yeah yes and that's
where I had you know I did four or five
of them and after like the fifth one I
was like you know I'm sick of like the
warning lights it's like dude just chill
out you've summers coming up go to Aspen
just write with your friends mm-hmm and
if you're alone if you need to suffer
just go a little harder that's that's a
that's a maturity that's a Nevel yeah I
think you know I need you in chat woody
46 yeah
so as you inch towards 50 you know how
do you you know and you know that you
can't you're not going to be able to be
you know at that level that you're used
to being at like being the only look if
somebody met waved a magic wand and said
okay you can the 50 you can do Kona you
can go race color uh-huh you go back in
the cave yeah well I don't know if I
would or wouldn't but you at that point
you wouldn't you are not competing for
the victory just I don't care who you
are you're not I mean let's everybody
else crap I could see you thinking like
I'm gonna I'm gonna give this everything
and see what I could do because that's
the one thing you haven't been able to
do but then you're can then you're then
you're there's a different type of
result I mean you could say oh as a 50
year old could you be top ten like
that's that's like winning yeah so you
could you set that as the bar yeah
but at forty six or I had this
conversation with Andrew Messick the
other day and we were talking about a
lot of things and I said you know what
I'm glad I didn't go to Kona in 2012 I
would have been lit up
I'd have been crawling down the road you
think so
why because it would because it took me
I wouldn't the nutrition hydration I
wouldn't have had dialed I would have
the pace you know just that that event
in my my sense that is that that event
takes a lot of experience and it took me
a long time seemingly a long time just
to figure out halves but the fools are
it's you know they're almost not even
comparable right so a little thing I
would have completely screwed it up and
I just I told her I was like thank you
yeah well when you listen to Mark Allen
who I know you had on your show and I've
had him on my show as well you know how
long it took him to master that and even
McCormack you know with all his brash
freshness and talents you know how many
years it took him to conquer that yeah
well so yeah and then then you know that
then you get into 40 and then you're
just getting farther and farther away
from from that
that magic doesn't age yes you're
getting experience but by the way you're
becoming an old man and so what about
the difference between did you swim this
morning by the way I did matter were you
I know I had kid drop-off and I was
trying to manage like I do the I'm a
morning person and Anna is an evening
person huh so I get the kids up and
start to get you know get them fed and
get their day going and then she likes
to sleep in so she sleeps a little bit
and then we both get up though she gets
up and then we take him to school and so
but they're not having said that I'm the
person that's you know boots up at 9
o'clock and she stays up till midnight
yeah I couldn't figure out how to make
it all work well you also said you you
were gonna do the group ride at 8:30 and
the swim practice started at like 7:15
it's close I was like there's no way
she's gonna get out early I don't swim
that's my mind when I'm first back in
the pool my I swim mm yes I can I can I
would have been out of there by 8:00
Rip's pretty fit and he was looking good
he's always fed you know he's a freak I
know but I'm interested in in in the
differences that that you've experienced
between you know cycling which is a team
sport and then moving into you know
triathlon which was your original sport
anyway you know the individual aspect of
that and then kind of what it's been
like to dip your toe in the water of the
ultras and the ultra running and the
linville's and and you know what kind of
you know how did that impact your
preparation you know your mindset
throughout those races at what are the
differences between those two worlds I
mean when I was running a couple of
years ago it was it wasn't structure you
know all of those cycling head structure
triathlon in 2012 had structure after
that I mean after the reason decision
came out and and I wasn't allowed to
compete I mean there's just no structure
I don't have an coach I don't I mean
in those days in those years I knew
exactly what I was going to do every day
for a week and then I get a new program
and then it would just and then we would
adjust or you have a test and and so the
with way more scientific and since then
it's I literally wake up check to
weather or maybe arrange it the night
before with some buddies hey you want to
run or I mean it's so casual right but
and with that too those years that I was
or that year that I was running I was
just my program if there was one was I
just kind of followed what everybody
else was doing so if these fast guys in
town were out doing a workout I would
attempt to sit in on the workout right
and and that would be my structure but
and they were way faster than me way
lighter than me and and if you injured
Runnings you got a little injured with
that right recently your back into it
well I'm starting to run a little more
now but I got yeah just my spoke of my
so has is just uh-huh gave out right
which is an important turns out some
really important muscle for me down well
also did you get all I'm about to turn
51 like you get you have to start paying
so much more attention all that annoying
stuff that you don't really want to do
though I'm rolling and all the rehabbing
kind of things yep and you get those
niggles much more easily yep you used to
but you know you go out and you ride
with these young guys loss and crack or
whoever you know like fast young pros if
you you know what would it look like if
you were to you know an alternative
university or to start coaching some
young some young athletes whether
triathletes are cyclists like what do
you see like even why because that I
never I never coached myself how am I
gonna I just listen to yeah but here's
the thing and this goes back to the
original question which is what gets
eclipsed tin the conversation about you
is that you have this you're sitting on
top of an unbelievable amount of
experience right and so you know how you
know what is it about that experience
that that we know less about you know
that could be helpful to young athletes
like you know when you're out with these
guys like and you're looking at them
you're like
to doing that you should be doing this
right you know yeah but it's more I mean
I think I mean look let's just use
Lawson as an example right because I he
does live here in Austin and he is on
the world tour and and I do train to
them and so last winter he's he's he
says you want to go for right I said
sure and I said how long we going he's
like six hours I'm sitting from right
okay I said well what do you do he's
like I have three one hour and fifteen
minute intervals at 290 ones and he's
not a big guy and I said for those are
listening at dawn that yeah I said what
what did you just say I said in it mind
you it's November uh-huh I was eating
[ __ ] apple cobbler and Blue Bell ice
cream in November and drinking beer and
staying up late and I'm like wait what
did you just say you're telling me
you're gonna do three hours and 45
minutes of intervals in November on a
six-hour ride he says yeah that's it
okay so I go on the ride and and at my
age and at my level all I can do is sit
on the wheel but I can stay on the wheel
but I'm sitting back so the to your
point I'm sitting there going what the
[ __ ] is this kid doing this is the
dumbest thing I've ever seen mean to be
that early in the year and like
hammering that hard yeah and there was a
lot more to it which I won't bore the
listener with but I said who is who told
you to do this
he says JB's doing the training Jonathan
butters I said well figures I mean that
that is so ill-advised and just nobody
can tolerate that because what like
what's the lesson like what is it that
you're trying to communicate about IED
preparation I think you have you got a
you got a like and lay the long to save
it nobody couldn't handle maybe there is
some person out there that maybe eddy
merckx could have done that loss and
kradic can't do that and it almost felt
like an experiment and I just thought it
was and I thought I tell loss in this
and I would tell JV this the that's that
that's not a fair experiment this is a
kid who's he doesn't have that
and what do you what do you what makes
you think that's kind of work and
fast-forward it destroyed him I mean if
this kid was on the sideline the entire
season and if he wasn't on the sideline
he was the first guy getting dropped so
to your point I mean for me I don't want
to sit here and go okay no not three
hours and 45 minutes of intervals how
about we do 510 or make up that's not my
thing but I can look at it from my own
experience you go yeah I don't think
that's a good idea
checking that it's November checking
that I know the athlete check-in that
you know a lot of other boxes and and
say no you got it you got to find a
better option here or you can then you
get into the technical parts of cycling
or strategy I mean those things I know
but I mean as far as you know creating a
training plan I just I was a listener
you know I always did all the way from
swimming age group swimming at 12 years
old all the way through I just said okay
what are we doing mm-hmm yeah but at
some point you you must be taking more
and more ownership of what you know
works for you right
the only owned the only in the sense
that I gave a lot of feedback and so we
were very the relationship between
Johanna myself and Ferrari and myself
was there was constant communication
there so if something if I felt like
something wasn't working or like any
athlete with any training plan you're
tired you need a little more recovery
you have a slight injury like that has
to be put on the table and theirs
doesn't do anybody any good hiding that
or being ashamed to talk about that
[ __ ] just say you know what I'm
destroyed is what loss and credit should
have done mm-hmm hey he didn't you kept
running the plan and digging a hole for
himself just tap out for a little bit
right so the message underneath that is
you got to know when to win a lot off of
gas and that perhaps too many people are
going too hard too often I mean
I think most people go yeah too hard
it's hard it's a different kind of
discipline ya know when to hold that and
if you talk about tries I'm in the tri
world is you you know this I mean the
the makeup of that athlete that's the
way they're wired at least think for a
few years and inevitably they all burn
out or get injured or just say okay I've
had enough right but they're wired to
just go hard and commit their life to
this and you know that might work for
some but I don't know that that works
for most well in the in the amateur
context it's it's yeah it's unbelievably
expensive and and and unbelievably
time-consuming so it doesn't lend itself
to longevity yeah and in the pros you
know there's so few people who can even
make a living doing this you know it's
crazy in the amount of energy and time
and discipline and focus that goes into
trying to compete at the highest level
of Ironman
it's unbelievable like unless you're in
the top percentile of those athletes
like I don't know how these guys get by
and it's a systemic you know issue that
needs to get addressed and fixed somehow
especially when you have this
organization this is making so much
money I know but that's the sport is not
about the tip of the spear mm-hmm that's
about the best track yeah that's that's
that's why when we did the stages when
we did stages for Kona and I had mark
Allen on and Dave Scott on you know well
you have to talk to them about 1989 and
the iron war and what that was like
I watched enough interviews that Bob
Babbitt did with them to know what they
could that what they're gonna say so you
gotta cover it in case you're listener
hasn't watched those interviews but I'm
Way more interested in saying okay mark
you know there's 2,000 people in Kona
today that are about to do a full
Ironman in four days like what came like
right speak to the middle of the pack
right I mean young for Danno he knows
yeah you know
Brenna carefree knows what they all they
got it so don't let's not talk to them
but and you know when you watch the NBC
coverage when it comes on you know well
it's all about those special stories
right that's the right letter of the
whole yeah yeah
so that's all I mean Messick and iron
man I mean that's I think they try to be
sensitive to the pros and prize money
and that part of the sport but by the
way I mean with their ownership
structure now that that that ownership
is not at all about who's gonna win this
weekend I mean it's it's about growing
the business building out more events
numbers numbers numbers hmm yeah well
you know and cycling has its own
problems as well I mean that's just a
[ __ ] show in so many ways I mean yeah it
was easy to take over if you turns out
it's easy to dominate a bunch of stupid
people
let's be honest and they really so
explain that well the the way would and
I don't mean to trying to sound like a
jerk or take people but the way Johan
and I came in this was a sport that was
easy to take over that they were stuck
in their ways they were we were coming
in the late nineties they were they were
still you know treating the sport like
it was the early eighties you know I
mean it could be you know the mentality
towards well I mean the the biggest
barrier that that probably still exists
today is their attitude towards women
you could never have a woman's one year
you could never have your wife at the
race you could never have her visit I
mean it was it was totally old-school so
that is I don't even know that yeah yeah
and I think and I that seems to have
changed but just the ability to are that
the the willingness to explore other
things whether it's technology or wind
tunnel or I mean
we first went to made it sounds so
obvious to go do reconnaissance you have
ten major climbs in the tour go spend
five days and get to just even though if
you think you know go there alone when
there's not a million people on them on
the hillside and just go do it
it was crazy with the first year we went
in 1999 we didn't see anybody in 2000 we
didn't see anybody but they started to
figure out that we were going in 2001 of
these riders were gone off them and
riding you know riding the course no I'm
for sure on yeah and so then we took it
from seeing the mountains to seeing all
the time trials and then after five or
six years there already what is doing
and so that is so I mean I'm embarrassed
to even say it is so obvious have you
have you seen the Icarus documentary I
have it but I've been asked about five
thousand times if I've seen it right and
I only have an eye you see ever do you
have a resistance to watch it no but not
at all I'd love to see it but I don't
watch TV at home i watch movies document
I love love love documentaries but I
only watch them when I travel and so I
could end up in my you know dumb self
the only way I know how to download
anything is through iTunes uh-huh
you have Netflix I have Netflix at home
but but you can't apparently and this is
what I'm told and I think it's right you
can't download a movie from Netflix on
your computer and all I have I can't
download you stream it if you have you
can stream it anywhere on your laptop or
whatever on a plane oh not on a plane
right the Internet's not strong enough
on a plane no so I mean you're all you
only watch mom when I'm forced to sit in
the seat for three hours right that's
how I passed the time so you can
download it to a mobile device your
phone or iPad I don't have an iPad I've
fallen I don't want to watch it on my
phone
but anyways I'm I'd love to see it I met
with with Fogel years ago when he was
when the when the movie was the original
movie you know where he was just the the
original conceit of the movie yeah I
don't like okay all right whatever
did he interview your on camera for that
mm-hmm oh he didn't yeah I had him on
the podcast recently I haven't published
that interview yet but it
I mean you should definitely watch it
you're incredibly fascinating and it it
will just change and color your
perception of sport and clean sport not
just in cycling but you know sport wide
and when you when you
he really is able to tap into the pro
funda t of this problem in a massive way
yeah and and when you realize the level
at which you know these practices are
being perpetrated it's it's it's
shocking and it's as a kid you know I
grew up I just there was nothing I love
more than the Olympics like that was
just the greatest thing ever
and you know I swam at Stanford and had
I shown up I was like a basically a
walk-on you know but had I shown up and
I found out you know all my heroes on
that team there was some kind of program
going on you know I don't know what I
would have done you know I probably
would have done who knows no I don't
know but but you know I can't shake
thinking about this movie and the extent
I mean basically these guys are saying
like nobody's won an Olympic medal is
clean you know like I don't know whether
that's true or not but with these these
people who are sort of sitting atop this
world of doping and anti-doping to hear
them say that it's it really you know
makes you think it makes you question
the future of sport and what can be done
to create an even playing field whether
that's even possible especially with all
the crazy technological advances and
Chris everything that's going on like
it's gonna get [ __ ] crazy you know I
don't know what that's gonna look like
and I'm still just trying to get eclipse
from being the most sophisticated doping
program in the history of the world well
yeah I think you're gonna live with that
for a while
unfortunately you know that is what it
is but you know I thought when you watch
this I mean well I it it pulls covers
and and makes you realize that this is a
problem that extends much more broadly
beyond cycling you know that sort of
takes the brunt of it and when you look
at the way that certain sports are
treated versus the NFL and the NBA and
and how we kind of you know take a blind
eye to those other sports and and the
that interests their play they're like
you know I don't know I don't know how
to even begin to unpack and address the
larger problem hmm yeah I don't either I
don't know well you should watch the
movie I will know I will what you know
how do you how do you communicate with
your kids about all this I mean I know
that's an ongoing conversation you've
got a son who's like a big-time football
player right now you know this has to be
something that comes up all the time
that they're dealing with especially the
younger kids is that our growing older
yeah you know so there's they are there
they're there are two waves of kids
there's the older ones who are high
schoolers two sophomores and then a
senior and then the younger ones were
first and third grade so obviously
totally different conversations you know
experience our experiences with our
interactions with their classmates but I
have to say you know my older ones lived
through it at a really key point in
their life when I was you know they
understood and they could you know
either hear about it in the hallway or
hear about it on social media or or
however and they really and this is I
think it's a testament to Austin and to
the schools here to the counselors to
the teachers to their friends to their
classmates we had very little drama for
lack of a better word with the with the
older kids and and at this point it's
never a conversation because I've been
so honest with them and so transparent
with them and it's a it's an open door
policy that if they ever do have a
question let's talk about it it's just
not it's just not an issue anymore and
but then that gets you to my younger
kids who of course when this went down
had no idea they were they didn't even
walk mm-hmm
so then you know the society that we
live in now which everything sits out
there and is forever
whether it's Oprah or Tyler Hamilton's
Bo
or a New York Times article or what are
this podcast it sits there forever so
while my older kids can obviously go tap
into that they probably won't because
they know they know everything pretty
much the younger ones are gonna grow
into it and so then they're gonna
they're gonna potentially you know watch
a documentary or read a book or watch
Oprah or listen to this podcast and then
and then you know then it's a whole
another wave of conversations hmm
so but I but you know what I'm fine with
that yeah I mean I that's not it it'll
never be a time and place where I say no
I'm not talking about anymore yeah you
have to you have to keep continue that
oh yeah what would happen if you know
Luke came home and said you know they're
doing steroids or you know I'm told I
should be doing this or or maybe I did
do it or you know have you thought about
that if you had that conversation no
it's interesting because it well I think
that this fight this the anti-doping
fight is you know I get asked all the
time should we just legalize everything
and my answer is always like no you
can't can't do that that's that's crazy
but they have a lot of so yeah so they
have said they need to exist these
agencies need to exist but when they
exist you know they have a lot of
messaging that really that I don't know
that I mean between you sadha and Jeff
Novitzky who was the federal
investigator who took down bonds took
down Marion Jones took me down you know
his main thing that he always thought
these Keys high schoolers his steroids
in high school steroids in high school
my son plays for what's like high school
he's a senior they're undefeated they
have that they've had ten NFL players
come out of that school they've won
multiple state championships they're
ranked third in the state today and it
lets Texas football since Texas this is
yeah this is Friday
this is this is the tibia stip that you
can get to the war yeah the war is being
waged here in some out level and let me
tell you something there is none of that
that's nothing
none of it and if there was I would know
and he zoom he's got aspirations to play
call no no no really
no no is he starting he starts yet Wow
tonight so why doesn't why didn't you
want to play wasn't one psychology
because he well he gets letters and gets
offers he doesn't want to he doesn't
want to play at a at a d2 school or a
smaller d1 school
I mean if look if he was at the level
where Florida and Alabama and University
of Texas and he different it'd be
different but if he's getting you know
I'm gonna make up some name and piss off
some of your listening you know southern
Kalamazoo you know tech he doesn't wanna
do that right where's he want to go to
school
hey what's good Alabama yeah he got
accepted we toured we had a great tour
he loved it but he don't he's not the
level or you could play ball there no
yeah that's a whole different paths of
all another yeah but essentially I mean
I just to me it's like wait but that's
the way politicians operate they have
these things that they that they put out
there to drive a little bit of hysteria
to drive their agenda but is that really
happening because I don't know so you're
seeing it yeah and I'm not saying that
there's not some kid and in Dallas or
Houston it's gotta be happenin there
right but I'm telling you I'm the best
football team or one of the best
football teams in this state at the
highest level that's not you know that
isn't even remotely a conversation huh
that's interesting well well you know
it's it's weird how it penetrates
amateur athletics to you know order
these stories about these amateurs and
Ironman stuff like that Cena's like in
cycling it's crazy you know yeah amateur
cyclists whether it's it's not their
career it's not their profession and
guys are getting caught doing this man
what do you see humility a healthy aging
clinics and I mean come on yeah
do you Oh people are competitive you
know says the most competitive man yeah
but I mean even even you know age group
triathlete said they don't want they
want to they want to either win their
age group or get a PR or and then that
all fits or meets this whole and you
probably had a [ __ ] ton of people on the
show talking about
biohacking and and whether it's diet
whether it's supplements whether it's
pharmaceuticals whether it's some new
technology i mean it's people
yeah and that and that line becomes very
gray a foreigner key you know what is
that you know it's if you you know I go
to the doctor and but do we care but do
we care well I think it's a it's a it's
a spectrum you know when it's on the
extreme yeah I think we care you know
what does it mean for a cyclist to get a
cortisone injection versus an NFL player
to get a cortisone injection but don't
we need another hour I read I read this
morning that the new president of the
UCI is going to completely ban
corticosteroids which is sort of a
tricky way to say it I mean it's really
cortisone and the the media loves saying
corticosteroid because it has the word
steroid but when in reality is no
cortisone is a catabolic agent not an
anabolic agent and so it's a very
different thing when when the public
hears corticosteroid they think anabolic
steroids hmm but it's not an anabolic
serum it's an anti inflammatory
catabolic agent not an anabolic agent so
yeah yeah well we could we could bark up
that tree forever it's you never ever so
you know as as this incredibly
competitive person yeah we kind of
explored this a little bit already but
you know do you think that you're you
you still have that in you or is that
dissipated like the I mean that's part
of who you are right so when you launch
a podcast
do you want to know why that Maitre
mindset like i have to be you know on
the top 10 and itunes or it's you know
i'm not gonna settle for anything last
like do you apply that everything that
you're doing or if you are you have you
chilled out I think I've chilled on that
I the I'm curious you probably the same
thing but I'm curious weekly on how the
public receives certain guests and the
numbers that you get how many downloads
did you get how many do you get caught
up and checking that stuff well I don't
I don't I don't ask I get told and if I
don't get told then I don't know and and
I I prefer it that way but that all sort
of changed when we did stages because
stages was last-minute
I didn't know I had very low
expectations on how it would do but as
it went from first week to second week
to third week and the numbers just
started to get crazy at that point I was
like okay I don't I don't even know what
to think I was I was I was shocked
humbled honored and then and then it was
then I got to this place where it was
cool to see I mean it was for me
personally you know to to generate that
kind of interest does that feel
redemptive I mean it's it's ironic it's
you know it's ironic that the one person
that the entire sport is banned from
mentioning spur-of-the-moment creates a
brand a channel content that is now
bigger than or ended up being bigger
than anything else the sport was doing
that's a little ironic mm-hmm and but
but at the same time old Lance would
have been like [ __ ] these [ __ ]
let's go this Lance has to be yeah let's
make this the biggest yeah let's show
everybody that you know I could dominate
this yeah I have to be thoughtful with
with it and yes the numbers are great
and but you know what they could be down
next year I mean that's my mentality has
to be that that that because I know this
better than anybody no you know nothing
lasts forever and so you know how I go
about just building that show developing
that show if we expand the show but
there can't be a I can't be in a place
where it's like haha told you so
or [ __ ] you yeah that's not gonna work
for you no I'm not and I'm not there I'm
not it's like wow that's what I tell
people like damn so that's not in the
back of your mind
ya know what do you think are the stones
that you still have to overturn like in
terms of just emotional development like
what are the things you still struggle
with that you battle with you know the
demons that you know you need to kind of
work through that are still kind of
looming out there and trip you up I mean
I don't there are still things that get
me aggravated but I mean it this through
this process that I've lived through is
you know I always gauge it based on like
when I walk down the street if I'm like
last week you know what ACL fest around
thousands of people you're walking
through thousand or you're walking in an
airport you're walking in New York City
like how you walk and how you feel like
are you when you see somebody they look
at you to you
you're like why are you or how like
what's what's my confidence level and
good confidence is different than
arrogance and man the way I walk down
the street now is so unbelievably
different that my confidence level today
if I walk down Fifth Avenue in New York
City versus ten years ago even 15 years
ago where it was couldn't have been a
bigger story you can't even you can't
even begin to compare those two and it's
weird and I and I I'm not bragging I'm
just being trying to be trying to
explain this and be honest about it but
it's it is [ __ ] lovely mm-hmm
there's something about removing that
dissonance between what you're saying
and how you're behaving
that kind of integrates you know the
human spirit in a certain way that I
think allows you to to be that way you
know and I think for me that's been a
big part of the journey you know one of
the one of the kind of core principles
of sobriety of recovery is you know not
just owning your past and aligning your
you know your actions with your words
and all of that but I'll give you also
give you an example so we go do and then
we gotta run cuz I gotta go you ask me I
take this podcast to the race in
Colorado and it was a whole lot of drama
around it because they tried to ban
Midway to do it was crazy but that was a
they actually did me a favor when they
did that so I I rent this Airbnb and I'm
and across and this is this cool part of
Denver called Ryan over it's all
breweries and and cool restaurants and
you know this were all the cool kids
hang out so the Airbnb is right across
the street from this brew pub so I'm
waiting on my uber to take me down to
the race and I'm with Liz Cruz whose
photograph me forever she's like oh
you've been spotted I was like okay
whatever long story short the Buber
pulls up not in front of the house but
in front of the brewery mm-hmm so we got
across the street and starting to rain
so we're about to get in the car and but
there's still people out on the patio
drinking and having a big old Sunday and
one of them goes hey Lance and I said
what's up man and he goes [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] he didn't stop uh-huh and then
there's like eight of them and then they
all start [ __ ] you [ __ ] you it was one
bullet and I was like I've never that's
never happened it happens in social
media it happens on you know how it
happens I'm just like in person to your
face I'm like oh my god and Liz was like
get in the car don't do anything and I
was I was like okay so I got in the car
and they're just of course while pulling
off here just keep there like it was
like a chant at that point
and I'm in the car and I said okay I
have to do something I can't I can't
just let this I can't just let this go
it's a call bar so let me talk to the
manager and the ladies like what's this
about so I was like see anyways he gets
on the phone I explained him everything
that happened
okay says man I'm really sorry that's
that's super [ __ ] up I said okay
here's the deal here's my credit card
the whole tab is on me but I want you to
go out there and tell him that I picked
up the beers and food and whatever they
had and I sent my love I think I was
like are you serious
I was like yeah so he goes out there I
mean then call me back later he's like
okay this is what happened so the moral
of the story is that you know ten years
ago five years ago two years ago maybe
even less that would have been a fight a
physical fight him and it just me just
go on you know what cuz it rocked me
because it has never does the first time
that's happened they're also getting
they're gonna have me being me has to do
something but might do something today
was you know what I'm gonna lean into
this one it's contrary action yeah do
you think you could ever get to a place
where you can forgive the David Walsh's
of the world
I mean Walsh is a Walsh is a special one
and we knew we'd need a whole nother
hour for him Walsh's I know David very
very well and David this is gonna sound
weird but David and I are very similar I
was a win at all cost guy David doesn't
win at all cost guy you know he'll tweet
he'll change I manipulate he'll lie
he'll deceive so he you know he has it
was it was he made it an industry and
Fairplay he's I think that's shifted for
him
he wasn't much interested in an apology
he was more interested in the lawsuit
and getting paid and he got that that's
exactly what he got and so if that's
what he wanted he got it but I also know
David - and and I know this story way
better than anybody else
so I'm very close not so much with him
but I know him well enough that I feel
close to him and I'm very close with him
all Riley so I see how he's so somebody
that he used as the pillar of this story
- to come after me I've seen the way
he's treated her and she's seen the way
he's treated her and I can tell you it's
not it's not an honorable mm-hmm so I
don't I don't I'm not uncomfortable with
where I sit in the world with regards to
him because the the ploys along the way
I know where they sit and you know
that's David I mean that's that's kind
of even you know right but I dig err
point I'm really getting at is is in
order to really be free you gotta like
release these resentments or whatever
they say I don't have any resentment
towards him yeah I'm not saying and I'm
not saying David per se I'm just saying
in general yeah I mean like in my
experience and kind of what I've gone
through it's like even when you feel
like you've been wronged and like this
person in that person yeah whatever it's
like you're the one who's suffering yeah
you know I don't want he's paying the
price for that resentment that you're
harboring and if you can get to a place
of like truly like letting go of that
then then you can walk down Fifth Avenue
in Manhattan yeah and you know be
integrated and I would say but I said
this at the top of the show there are
still a few things right and that the
postal case being one but almost all of
those have been in it's a process I
don't think anybody's you know goes on a
Hiawatha trip or goes to counseling once
or goes to AAA and walks out it's like
okay
I'm good I'm forgiving everybody this is
this is your life it's a long hike and
so you know they're getting [ __ ] I'm not
gonna sit here and lie to you or anybody
listening and said okay they're all gone
I'm not gonna sit there and lie to you
and say it doesn't [ __ ] make me live
it and pissed off that LIVESTRONG did
but they did because it does so yeah
it's it's there but hey I'm gonna work
through it right and I'm committed and
it's and if you if you just said I'm not
gonna work I'm not gonna do the work
well then you did then you have a
problem and so but you know Walsh lost
walleston Walsh elicits no emotion me
Travis Tygart elicits no emotion me I
get it
I know exactly and I'm good with that
and I'm me I wake up as me every day and
I like waking up as me and it's not
called forward for nothing and so yeah
there are a few more I got to pick off
and and make right and they might it
might happen next month it might take
three years I don't I don't know but the
qiyan is that you should you know this
is that as so long as I realize that
that that that is a process and I am
committed to making to shedding that
pretty powerful it's a good place to end
it man yeah yeah thanks yeah great sorry
I know this is short for you but yeah I
know yeah man I go I don't go rogon
length but I do the bad guy if I don't
all right yeah no problem man thanks for
your time so you're easy to track down
on the Internet yeah Lance Armstrong we
do sport calm stages podcast for
podcasts yeah it's all there yeah right
on man I'm not very good about
leveraging and promoting and pushing
that stuff out but there's some good
ones out there if people are interested
yeah cool man thanks David Anchorage
peace what's so hot bastard jaws from
this morning
we only went like 2900 it was all sprint